[Musique]
ça n'est jamais arrivé dans l'histoire
du monde que la technologie avance avec
telle vitesse et le résultat c'est que
toutes les structures sociales mondiales
sont
bouleversées je ne pense pas que on
puisse continuer c'est ça le sujet de
mon livre le siècle des menaces on peut
pas continuer comme ça ça ne va pas
continuer comme ça va continuer comme ça
ça ne va pas continuer comme ça quoi que
raconte nos dirigeant de quelque parti
qu' soit il y a rien à faire l'humanité
va dans le mur et on y peut rien et ça
c'est le genre de considération qui
échappe au public
[Musique]
complètement plus de productivisme ou de
consumérisme ne peut pas guérir les mots
du consumérisme plusuc
peut pas guérir les mots du
[Musique]
consumis et je suis pas pour
l'Apocalypse la
catastrophe je dis simplement voilà la
situation elle est très simple vous avez
une quantité finie de ressources
[Musique]
et cette quantité finie elle sera un
moment ou un autre consommé
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de controverse des gens
qui disent mais non pas du tout ça va
s'arranger alors on dit l'homme s'en est
toujours tiré voilà ça c'est le
raisonnement classique on a toujours
trouvé des solution on va s'en tirer
donc les gens qui parlent d'épuissement
se trompent
[Musique]
laovere est là mais je crois que c'est
pas vrai nous sommes dans une situation
jamais vue on peut pas dire l'homme s'en
est toujours tiré aujourd'hui c'est pas
[Musique]
vrai les
pénuries seront aggravé par la science
la technologie au cont de ce qu'on
pense et donc c'est vrai mais ce qui est
arrivé c'est que la machine s'est
emballée personneait pensé quand j'avais
24age je personne ne pensait que la
machine allait s'emballer
[Musique]
oui je sortirai de ce monde où l'action
n'est pas la sœur du R
[Musique]